so far as industry tools I would like to
grant them more confidence less bravado
more confidence so the ability to walk
in comfortably and start building
relationships because truly this is a
business of relationships and you know
certainly I want all my writers to be
able to pitch well what not but it
starts with a certain level of believing
and the value of the work truly
understanding it and being able to
parlay that in a room so that is an
incredibly important tool for me the
ability to walk into a room to start to
network to make some relationships can
you give me an example of bravado versus
real confidence bravado versus real
confidence is quite simple this is the
greatest script ever oh my god it's
gonna make five hundred million dollars
domestically because it's the greatest
thing that was ever written
that's bravado it's completely baseless
it doesn't speak to anything other than
the writers fantasy confidence speaks to
the ability of a writer to sit down and
say I want to talk to you about
something that I wrote that I'm really
excited about I wrote it inspired by my
relationship with my father who was a
forensic psychologist who also happened
to abuse his mother and children this is
somebody who can just sit down and talk
about the work and there's difference I
think I feel that a lot of writers make
a lot of empty promises about the work
and I see it on pitches all the time
when I went over a pitch with with a
team of writers a few days ago who say I
hope this is just the greatest complete
conspiracy ever in the history of
America why what happened what the hell
are you talking about talk to me about
what it is rather than what you want it
to be or how powerful you want me to see
it as I find that writers who are
confident in the work who have done the
work and there's only writers who've
done the work who've gotten notes who've
gotten the feedback they can walk in
truly confident they can walk in and
just talk to you about the work they
don't need to do an interpretive dance
to go along with it they don't need to
promise you that I'll make
millions of dollars or that you know
Americans will tune in every Friday
night and droves to see the show they
know what the work is so it's the
confidence to be able to sit down talk
about the work as a professional to
another professional on the other side
of the table
you